Turkey's put its most populated areas
under a 2-day lockdown to try to contain
the spread of the virus
people rush to grocery and convenience
stores after that announcement 31
provinces are affected including the
biggest cities of course as Istanbul and
Ankara bakeries hospitals pharmacies in
workplaces making medical equipment are
exempt the lockdown is due to end on
Sunday midnight turkey confirmed 98 more
deaths from the virus on Friday bringing
the total number to more than a thousand
same Costello joins us live now from
Istanbul so soon and this you know the
world's been dealing with this for a few
weeks now why why just now are these
restrictions coming happening in Turkey
well turkey is actually one of the
countries that took earlier measures
against the a covered 19 virus however
when it comes to announcing a lockdown
especially for an economic capital like
Istanbul with more than 15 million
people they have been a little late
because Turkish president and the
government actually has believed that
the economies countries economies will
should keep whirling which means the
logistics and supply lines shouldn't be
cut because there are 80 million people
and especially Istanbul is like the
locomotive of the Turkish industry and
Turkey let's keep in mind that is a
transit country for all international
logistics from is to west so that's why
they have encouraged self-isolation and
they they banned people below 20 years
old and above 65 years old from going
out schools are closed cafeterias
restaurants they have been all shut down
and it's been weeks and all
international flights have been
suspended even domestic flights are
suspended in a way as well however
because the weather has been nice in the
last three days people have been going
out more and even yesterday Rochelle
Friday was like a regular Friday in
Istanbul and the main news bulletins
they have criticized this crowd and
Istanbul as well especially in the old
town that we call historical peninsula
the traffic was heavy yesterday that's
why it was a sudden
unprecedented announcement of a lockdown
yesterday and the circular was not
announcing lieutenancy
as the lockdown was and and so at the
beginning people didn't know that the
bakery's health centers medical Parma
C's would be opened that's why they
flock to the supermarkets as I said 15
plus million population in some will and
you have millions of Syrians in Istanbul
and life is continuing in a way that's
why there was a bit of a chaos not a bit
of a but actually a great chaos last
night and then the interior minister
important people that the bakeries would
be open and turkey is a country that has
suffered many military coups many
curfews especially during 80s people are
used to that but still it's a panic
because people have families to feed
people have children and the economic
conditions in Turkey is not as as good
as before that's why many people don't
have budgets to stock route or supplies
in their home and especially the basic
things like bread is necessary that's
why people flocked in the supermarket's
but since the early hours of today it
has been quite in major cities like
Istanbul the capital Ankara people are
at home and this is for two days for now
but many say that many believe that the
government's will need to extend this
for all coming weekends as this weather
is coming better and it is difficult to
stop Turkish people from going out
Michelle all right Sandra casillo live
from Istanbul sinem thank you